- So everyone was talking
about this though,
we love Friends, but everyone
was talking about this moment.
It happened at the SAG awards,
- Oh yeah.
- and I have a question.
- Okay.
- So let's show the picture,
- All right.
(audience aws)
- like I've been dying for
another Romy and Michelle,
like are y'all gonna do it?
Will you do it for us?
- We would love to do it.
- Okay. It would be great.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
(audience cheers)
- It's like such a,
everyone loves that movie.
- I like how I'm acting like oh you would?
Okay then, yes. The we will.
- Yes, yes.
- I am a decision maker.
I love them, y'all planned that obviously,
you were like let's show
up and do something like,
cause y'all were-
- Yeah, well we were
asked 'cause they said
the theme was back together again.
So they asked Mira and I
to present and Mira said,
"Hey in the script it says ensemble.
And so we should be wearing ensembles."
And I went immediately to
what we wore in the movie.
I was like, ah, I don't
know if I can do that,
it really sounds like a lot of work.
And then someone showed me a picture
of this pink sequin tuxedo.
I went, well, I can do that.
And Mira can wear a blue suit.
- Oh my God.
- And she did.
- She did, you looked
fantastic, it was amazing.
- Oh, thanks yeah.
(audience cheers)
- And it's awesome 'cause
people attach themselves
to these characters that y'all get to play
and we love and then for
y'all to like do that,
it's really cool.
- It was fun.
- It's nostalgic for everyone.